hello everyone
welcome to rational science
why is it rational why do we call
ourselves rational
well because everybody out there
is irrational who tries to do physics or
science why are they irrational well
they're irrational because they move
concepts around
during their physical interpretations
they uh
transfer energy they vibrate or excite
the field they move a charge
they move a mass you know all those are
concepts you can't move
concepts around and then the other
reason is that a lot of people or just
about everybody out there
as far as i know everyone out there
mediates everything with particles
discrete
particles and there is not a single
phenomenon of nature
that is invisible and intangible that
you can explain in a rational manner
with particles with ex discrete
particles
okay and here we do it with something
else we have
elongated entities which we propose
those are
the electromagnetic ropes and those are
going to mediate not only light but
gravity we have
what you could call the grand unified
theory
it's not a mathematical theory it's a
physical theory
we have lighting gravity and one
mechanism
okay and that's the essence of this
channel
today we're going to talk about these
so-called particles that quantum
mechanics proposes
in fact we're not going to talk about
the particles we're going to talk about
something else we're going to
we're going to talk about the quasi or
quasi or
quasi i call them the quasis
because i think you got to be crazy to
believe them the
the quasi particles okay so
uh that's uh what we're the subject
matter of today if you're not interested
in
quasis well stick around you might learn
something
stay anyways uh where do we start well
we have to distinguish
the quasis crazy particles
from what uh quantum mechanics i guess
refers to as the real particles the
authentic particles
you know what's the difference well if
if you go to the uh to the standard
model
quantum mechanics okay you won't find a
single
quasi in there these are crazy too but i
mean uh
you don't find any of the quasi-crazy
particles in there
okay and you say well why not aren't
should those be in the standard model of
elementary particles
i mean they're particles right so you
would think
they should be in there okay so
in order to see what happened here you
know i want to show you today a little
bit of history of how we moved
from real particles when
the old days people really thought in
terms of real particles real
balls uh today they're known as
classical particles corpuscles
grains of sand whatever you want to
think of it as such little beads
and from there we moved to quantum
particles
okay which are those over there
essentially and then from there we move
to the quasis
okay so we're getting more and more
abstract as we go along so we need to
understand
what has happened here okay and
a good way of to start this is to see
how we came up with the
with these particles i mean where do
these particles come from
and so let me give you a little history
on this
here it is this is chronology of
particle discoveries okay
and the first particle i think you could
say for
invisible intangible phenomena remember
that's what we're looking at here you
know
the the the sandbox we know sam you can
get a grain of sand in your hand you can
see it you can touch it
you know what it is okay there's
something different this is has to do
with
modeling simulating the invisible
intangible world with particles okay and
so
since those particles are intangible and
invisible
well you know they say these are
particles it's all mediated with
these these gazillions of particles that
are all around us
and of course the first particle was the
photon in other words
uh people even before 500 bc
they started wondering you know what is
light especially light
i don't think they had a notion of
gravity yet uh
you know they didn't really they took it
for granted you know things fall to the
floor they didn't
i don't think anyone studied that at all
okay
maybe i'm wrong okay but light is
something that did concern them and they
said what is light
and so the first thing that came to
their minds is particles
okay and the particles uh that they
invented in those days or that they had
in mind
came out of the eyes it was the superman
theory of light you know superman he's
got this x-ray vision
it's not that light comes to his eyes
light goes
from his eyes through the wall and sees
the girl next door okay that's the way
it works
and uh yeah for many years you had these
people
uh first the greeks okay and they
believed that
uh light came out of the eyes and went
to the objects the farther an object was
away well
the less you could see it and at some
point you couldn't see it any longer
like at the horizon
and so the light rays coming out of your
eyes did not reach that far
that was the notion it would be ah hazen
al hazan
10th century and he came up with this
notion that
after studying light he said no light
comes from the objects to
the eyes okay so so he reverted that
direction
but it was still particles it was all
done with particles that that's what
they thought it was
and that lasted even until the 17th
century when you had all these
folks and there are a whole bunch more
i'm just mentioning probably the most
prominent ones
galileo descartes and uh
newton and they believe in particles
essentially they
didn't see a reason to change that at
all
uh robert hook we don't have a picture
of him because
he was a deadly enemy of newton
and he was also the right-hand man of
robert boyle and when robert boyle died
hook essentially was the caretaker of
the royal society
and when hook died well newton took over
for the first time he became a member
of the royal society and he erased all
vestiges
of robert hook including his picture so
we don't have a picture of him today
but robert hook was the guy who came up
with the wave
in his micrographia book
i think it was 1665. uh he's the first
one who mentions that light might be
comprised of waves and that was taken up
later on by christian higgins who
went in there and analyzed it in more
detail but even in the case of
waves when huygens and all these other
people
analyzed the way they were thinking of
this they were thinking of the ether
and ether was a bunch of particles and
these particles moved up and down
and they created this wave which was
supposed to be light
okay in contrast newton held that
uh it wasn't really uh that
um like uh
that the ether was waving it's that
something was traveling through the
ether again
particles and they were traveling
straight so it was a question of
straightness versus
undulating that that's essentially what
the fight between
uh the wave theorists and
the particle theorists was it was
straight versus you know waving
up and down and and again
newton could not figure out how light
could travel other than
you know in a straight line anyways the
photon was
particles okay it was essentially the
first particle
and even to this day continues to be a
particle in the eyes of all the
mathematicians
who vouch for quantum and in fact for
relativity as well
and for strength theory okay keep in
mind strength theory
talks about a line 1d line what is the
1d line made of well it's made of zero
dimensional
points okay so what is each point made
out of
lines and what is each line made out of
points it just goes on and on and on
okay so everybody essentially is dealing
with particles
and it turns out that with particles you
cannot explain a single phenomenon
of nature which is invisible and
intangible such as gravity
uh magnetism or light
okay uh about 400 bc we have
lucifus and uh lucipus and
democritus and these folks came up with
the atomic theory i don't know if they
were the originators
but um they're credited with it and they
came up and they said look uh the
universe is made up of atoms
everywhere okay especially anything
that's got matter
uh they probably thought also that air
and everything
else was made out of atoms as well um
that notion would last for hundreds of
years until
in uh 1876 we have this fellow a german
guy
he just he was a glass glassmaker and he
came up with a cathode rays
okay that's what he named them uh in uh
in german they were translated as
catholic rays
uh but they didn't really know what
those cathode rays were it wasn't until
joseph
john thompson he came up with the notion
that
the cathode rays were made of electrons
and they called them negative
arbitrarily i guess
and those um electrons as
thompson would uh theorize
according to mathematical physics it's
called proof
and in rational science we call it
theorize he was proposing
uh making an assumption simulating and
saying that
uh the electron was part of the atom was
it
was a separate part of the atom you had
the atom and you had the
electron okay and the way he envisioned
that was uh the plum pudding modem
model as it's known he said there's this
atom
and it's got these negative
i guess you could call it fruits
embedded in it that was his model but he
did
think of the atom as being comprised of
these negative
pieces that fit into the atom as a
separate in other words the electron was
a separate piece
within the atom okay uh rutherford
would show i show it as 1919 because
that's when he wrote this paper but
he really didn't realize that until like
five years later
that uh that there there was this
thing he called he thought it was
hydrogen atom but it was really the
proton
what he was thinking of and he saw it as
a particle
he thought uh that the center of the
atom consisted of this
main particle which weighed about 1800
times
more than the electron and that the
electron was a bead that rolled around
it
and that notion developed between him
and
niels bohr a couple others as well so
they came up with this planetary notion
of the atom
now we had a proton particle electron
particle and on top of that we had still
our beloved photon okay so we had these
three particles
but it didn't stop there paulie
welcome pauline what is it 1930 he came
up with a notion
of the neutrino
he was probably thinking of the neutron
because there was a
confusion at the confusion at the time
between the neutrino and the neutron
they had different functions and they
kind of mixed them
together and they said oh you proved
this but you you were really talking
about that
that sort of thing okay and that was the
neutrino wasn't
uh proven to exist according to
mathematical physics
proof right evidence until uh
many years later uh what is it 1956
cowan and his partner they allegedly
proved the existence of the neutrino
meanwhile in 1932 fermi comes up with
the
notion of the neutron i think it was
like mid-year
and at the end of that year chadwick ran
an experiment
and proved again in mathematical terms
proved the existence of the neutron okay
positron uh we have the electron
this negative electron this is a
positive electron
otherwise known as the positron okay we
don't know what the difference is
physically all we know is this one
carries a negative sign this one carries
a positive sign
because that's how they behave they
if if they're opposite they attract that
sort of thing
and so that's why they put these labels
mathematical labels that have
no meaning whatsoever in physics okay
negative and positive
and so in 1930 direct came with the
notion of
his direct sea which con the sea which
really formed space itself the vacuum
and it was the vacuum was made of
positive and negative particles that
blended together formed i guess nothing
in his mind and again known as the
direct scene
and for that he created the positron he
theorized the positron
anderson supposedly discovered it
six years later 33 also
fermi came up with a weak force uh he's
the guy who theorized about it that
wasn't going to be discovered until
1983 way at the bottom the w pluses way
uh w minuses and the z
uh bosons okay so it took a lot of years
to
apparently prove their existence to the
mathematical community
even though everybody believed in them
throughout this whole time okay
uh 35 yukawa uh discovers the
or or theorizes the pi
uh maison and uh anderson and one year
later the
mu meson they shortened that to pion and
muon
uh two particles again of the standard
model there
uh higgs and about a hundred other
people
in the sixties they proposed the higgs
boson the higgs field
this notion was arising in the quantum
community
his wasn't the only guy he just got the
noble for it because i guess he was
british
and they gave it also to englert another
fellow who allegedly discovered it
before him so
you know all that is just politics out
there
um there were a lot of others involved
there
anyways the higgs supposedly uh one of
the last particles to be
included within the standard model you
will never find the graviton in there
and never will
okay the graviton has not been
discovered and never will be discovered
except by uh virtue of the magic wand
they're gonna force fitted in there if
anything someday but they have
no way of showing the graviton okay
the graviton for all practical purposes
doesn't exist
never existed never will exist okay
and uh uh then we have the quarks
uh zweig uh also said he
had it before gelman and uh but
gentleman got the
nobel prize and zweig was a little
ticked off about that
okay he wasn't even considered even
though he says he came up with a quark
uh politics again uh and then the
germans uh
deci they discovered the strong force
the gluon
78 79 even though it was uh again uh
theorized long time ago and that
essentially completes the
standard model so here it is one more
time
okay let me put it up here okay that's
that's what we have there
and you can see there are no quasis
no crazy particles in there all we have
is these uh
particles that form part of the standard
mod
okay so how is this any different than
the quasis the quasi part of the
quasi-particles or whatever you want to
call them
uh well you heard of um quasimodo
you know he's uh this ugly guy who
crept up the church cathedral the notre
dame cathedral in france
and he fell in love with this beautiful
girl
okay and he
swept her off her feet in a sense here
let me show you
what i'm talking about for those of you
who don't know the tale okay
here it is hey that's quasi there
and he climbs around you know he's gonna
save the girl you know
and she she was facing the gallows there
and he's gonna sweep her off her feet
and take her away
save the day okay
so yeah uh
[Music]
why do i mention this fella well i
mentioned him because
um you say why was he called
quasimodo well it turns out that
you you might think he's half a man or
maybe like a man
or not quite a man maybe halfway between
man and beast or whatever
he had his hunchback he had it you know
this uh
warty desire or whatever um
no he was uh named quasimodo because
he he was uh when he was born they
realized parents
realized he was born so ugly so
so out of whack that they decided to
turn them over to the church so they
left them in a little basket at the door
of the church and left
and they said let the church worry about
this guy and
they did it on quasimodo day
they did it or i think it was the day
before they left them
at uh at the door of the church and
here's what
quasimodo means in uh
latin okay and it's uh the sunday
um uh it's the sunday after easter
okay and it comes from quasimodo and
the first words of the in trade with uh
android
which is uh the entrance okay uh
the priest comes into the church okay on
that day
and and it's this entrance it's called
the
quasimodo uh geniti infantis
okay and what does that mean what means
as if a newborn babe
okay so you entered the church and you
kind of entered
as a babe and that's how quasimodo
entered there
so it means so the important part here
is the quasimodo
you know quasimodo means as if and so
they use this quasi or quasi or
quasi again i call it quasi in the case
of
quantum uh as a
kind of like okay it's not quite
but almost there okay so in the case of
the
quasi or crazy particles we're talking
about
something that's in the process of
becoming a particle it's not quite a
particle
it's trying to make it to be a particle
trying to graduate into a particle
okay and you might say well
you know when did this start this
quasi-crazy
particles uh was this something
recently it turns out that you know we
had
our first quasi in in the 19th century
in the early
19th century and it was this fellow here
and his name was russell he was a
shipbuilder
and what he did was um one day he was uh
watching how a ship came in i remember
you're talking about
wooden ships ship comes in and
docks but as soon as it kind of slowed
down and stopped
he found that the wave that it created
continued rolling by
and he was on a horse and he chased that
wave down he
he went along the bank of the river and
just
watched it all the way because he caught
his attention
and he found out that this wave just
kept rolling along
and he called it a wave of translation
and wrote about that he even built
in his garage he built a little device
that created waves and studied
waves okay he called them wave of
translation
and that wave of translation is going to
become in the 20th century
going to become this solaton okay and
that's the first
crazy that we have on the books okay
and what is a soliton well it's a
self-reinforcing wave packet
that maintains its shape while it
propagates at a constant velocity
and here you have a couple examples
there's more examples
of this sultan wave
and it's a fascination with a lot of
these mathematicians they study it they
get equations on this they study them
from every angle
for them it's a big thing we have no use
for these things
in science in physics
maybe explaining them that's all that's
where
the scientific part stops
but we don't go beyond that they're
nothing more than curiosity
that's it and
that that happened in 19th century but
nobody thought about these
quasi-particles you know or solitons or
whatever
you know until the 20th century uh after
the mid
20th century you have this fellow he's a
soviet scientist soviet
mathematical physicist okay he worked on
the soviet bomb
and his name was lev landau 1956 he has
to invent the
quasi-particle for the first time
he brings it into into the vocabulary
okay so what is it well he used it to
explain
a theoretical model of interacting
fermions
okay and these crazies uh
describe the normal state of most metals
at sufficiently low temperatures
in other words you have you're talking
about again collective
uh motion and he's going to apply this
to
liquids and and to metals
okay and his theory explains why some of
the properties of
interacting fermion systems are very
similar to those of
ideal fermi gas okay that is
non-interacting fermions and why
other properties differ and
lambda reasonably the reason that what
interactions do
is to produce virtual particle hole
pairs
where did he get that well he got it
from mr direct
and they were dealing with all these
particles and holes
and positive and negative coming
together and forming this background
and he applied that notion the same
notion that direct had for his sea
he applied it to uh solid state he's
applied it to several parts of uh
of what they call mechanical and
electrical physics
okay okay um
so what came out of all that uh well
uh here's the definition first of
quasi-quasi
crazy as i call them uh just so you know
i'm repeating this from last time
quasi-particle is a collective
excitation
their emergent phenomena when you have
many
uh for example atoms or molecules
or photons or electrons vibrating in
such
ins in in a given way
well they call that collective
excitation a quasi particle
that's that's all it is they call it a
particle
that behavior that collective behavior
is called a particle and there you see
an example at the bottom
just one example by the way there's i've
shown others uh
the other day so you can check on the
previous videos you'll find some
other examples okay and
from that they came up with all these
lists of quasi particles that to this
day all the mechanics
of quantum everywhere in the world this
is what they do
this is what they do for a living they
study quasi particles
they've forgotten about the standard
particles about the atom they learn that
in kindergarten
uh physics when they're getting their
masters that's kindergarten physics you
know
what a proton is what an electron is
what a muon is a pion
they left that stuff behind now they've
evolved and
now they talk about what crazies they're
into the crazy world
why because they have to they get a job
somewhere and usually get a job
in a manufacturing place either as an
engineer
or to study or to develop or
you know some product and so they go in
there and they try to
study behavior uh collective behavior of
particles
okay and so they gave names to all these
behaviors because this guy studies this
thing this other guy studies that other
thing
and what happens out of this they they
had to give them names so that they
could put them in their
writings you know they publish papers
and they say what are we going to call
this well we'll call this
uh quasi-particle this and the other guy
says i'll call it that
okay and so they have all these
different names for these different
quasis
kind of crazies and here's a list of
them okay
uh there's probably more of these uh
out there i i i'm mentioning probably
90 of them probably and
again i must have missed a couple here
and there this is uh
what the standard model of quasis looks
like okay
uh you've got all these uh
so-called particles and what they are
they're all collective
excitations of something okay in fact
look at the
last one the wrinklon uh
it's got to do with wrinkles okay and uh
you'll
you'll see some of them like the orbiton
there you know it's got to do with orbit
on you got the ocelons got to do with
oscillations okay um
well i'm going to mention uh real
quickly here
uh perhaps the what is it the plasma
plasmon got to do with plasma
okay so these are the particles that
these people study
and they're not really particles they're
collective excitations
that they go into the lab they can't see
or touch what they're analyzing
and so they theorize about it but then
they introduce the word proof
and exist and evidence they introduce
these words
because they say we've proven it we
found we discovered
because they got to get their noble or
their wolf prize or whatever prize out
there and they say look we did something
for humanity we discovered
this particle well did you discover
like a particle like a little bead a
little
grain of sand no it's not even close
because we're not even talking about a
quantum particle that's in the standard
model
we're not talking about a little ball
which is not a ball even there
in that case they're talking about an
excitation of
many particles and that's what all these
particles are
excitations of many particles and let me
go through some of these
just so that you get a feeling okay i'm
not going to go through all of them by
the way
i don't want to bore you to death but i
want you to get the hang of
what these people are up to what you're
paying for because
these people rely on government funds
in almost all cases either directly or
indirectly
they depend on uh grants
and also on rich people contributing to
their specific pet
projects okay so there's a lot of money
going into
this research into quasis
crazies okay and here's uh
uh i'll just review real quickly here
this is the phone on i presented the
other day and there's several
uh types of phonons you can see there
each one of these vibrations is a
different phonon
so you got work there job security for a
lot of so-called physicists mathematical
physicists
who study each one of these different
types of vibrations
okay and those are the phonons those are
people who specialize in phonons
okay uh i mentioned this this is
probably an even more important field
which is the
uh holes okay and i showed this the
other day where you have the holes
going in uh from to the negative pole
or negative terminal of a battery why
because the electrons the negative
electrons are going in the opposite
direction
leaving a hole in the valence band of
the
atom and that movement
of the hole opposite of the uh
of the electron bead that's flow
is considered a positive current okay
so so that's what how this came about
and again this is important in in the
semiconductor business which i worked on
quite a bit because of this because what
happens when you put a
p-type and an n-type crystal together
they form what is known as a depletion
layer and the electrons allegedly
uh go through the barrier and neutralize
those atoms
okay so they become it creates this
neutral region known as a depletion
region
and so this is important semiconductors
and
one of the things i want to mention
today and that's got to do with the fact
that all these
so-called quasis they have to do
not with science they have to do with
technology
okay that's why they're important
because
you know people don't care if you
understand
the invisible world out there they don't
care if you can explain it in a rational
manner that's out the door
they don't even care about that anymore
what they say this how we're going to
explain it but that's not important the
important thing is to discover
the behavior whatever behavior you're
studying
uh giving it a name always
ending it on oh on okay on it's gotta be
a
on to be a particle okay and
you give it a name and you study it and
you use it for something you don't
understand it any more than uh
edison understood electricity what
electricity is he he didn't need to know
that he just needed to develop the
filament
for the light bulb and so you know
because
he was working on developing a gadget
so he doesn't need to know what
electricity is or how to explain it or
anything like that he didn't need to
have a physical interpretation for
electricity
what he needed was to develop a gadget
and so they said well you know you send
electricity here you produce this effect
and it
creates light and that's what we need to
sell out there to
the people and make our company and the
investors
richer that's all it was about and this
is no different
this these are people who are studying
semiconductors in the case of holes
right
and what they do they study you know the
semiconductor but they don't understand
what what's happening there in real life
they simulate it always with particles
because that's the easiest thing to
um to put an equation to
you know you can describe it with an
equation much better if you've got a
particle then
for example an extended entity like
we're proposing such as a rope
okay so that's how the particle keeps
having uh an everlasting life it never
dies
because it's easy for the mathematicians
to deal with particles because they can
put a value
you know for the point particle for
whatever value it's got they can put
that in the equation
okay so this is the issue they don't
understand it but they don't care if
they don't understand or not the
important thing is can you develop a
gadget that makes us money
that's what it's about right okay so
let's go through
a couple of these here's the anyone okay
and just go f alphabetically through a
couple of these just so you get the hang
of it what is this
uh is it some kind of bean
is it some kind of uh grain of sand
a little pearl of some kind no it's a
type of
quasi right that occurs only in two
dimensional systems two-dimensional
system
what the hell i i thought the
two-dimension was
outlawed in our real world and these
people say
the anion only belongs to two
dimensional systems which is going to
give you an idea that they're talking
about maybe geometry
for sure mathematics for sure
guaranteed not physics in a
two-dimensional world two identical
anions
change their wave function they change
their wave functions
like if a wave function is something you
change you know you
trade or you exchange or throw away or a
kick or a jump or whatever
when when they swap places in ways that
can't happen in three-dimensional
physics
okay so now we move from three
dimensional physics to two-dimensional
physics they
are going to use this anion this process
of
circling one particle around another is
referred to by its mathematical name
as braiding okay they call it braiding
okay so
these things are going to twist around
each other sounds like
this like a rope braiding maybe
okay uh braiding uh
encodes information in a more robust way
than
other potential quantum computing
technologies
so what does this have to do with
science no it's got to do with
technology
with gadgets with inventing stuff okay
not a billion uh billion anions were
detected by two experiments in 2020.
did they detect a particle no th they
detected a behavior
a collective behavior of many particles
and they call that
whole behavior which is more or less
localized because they're talking about
a microscopic world and they say oh
it behaved in this way we're going to
call that what an anion
okay and not a billion anions have not
been
definitely detected although this is an
active
area of research okay so this is what
you're paying for you're
paying for these people to do research
and development on two-dimensional
uh things uh
non-physical okay uh so that means
they're just gonna describe it
mathematically
and what for for technology not for
science
at all has nothing at all to do with
science or physics
but it's included within mathematical
physics and it's a very strong
area of research okay okay
let's continue here with uh the next one
on the list again i'm just going to go
alphabetically through a couple of these
just so you get the hang of it
this is the bion nothing to do with sex
okay
just because it's got the uh prefix by
in there
the bound state of two solitons remember
what a soliton was it was a wave
okay somehow it became a particle and
they take two solitons okay
and they say if these two have a bound
state they're kind of interlocked
you know uh maybe entanglement
one soliton somehow affects another one
from a distance we don't know how or why
we don't care because we're just doing
technology right
or in systems where the bound state
periodically oscillates a breather
okay what's a breather a non-linear wave
somehow the particle converting the wave
wave goes to particle
that duality okay that comes in handy
okay annoying
for them because you'll never find a
wave in the standard model
in which energy concentrates in a
localized and oscillatory
fashion there it is in a nutshell
then we have the bipolaron type of quasi
okay quasi
consisting of two polarons you don't
have one we have two okay so what's a
polaron well it's a quasi
used in condensed matter physics to
understand the interactions between
electrons and atoms in a solid material
okay so we're talking about interactions
here they call that a polaron then they
take two polarons which is two
interactions and
and they're gonna have a uh what is
called a bound state which is
essentially
um action at a distance entanglement
that's essentially what they're talking
about between particles
and they're not really particles they're
between electrons but they're not
talking about an electron anymore
or a positron or anything like that a
discrete particle
which is not a particle to begin with
but they're talking about the
excitations of many of these particles
so they have a bunch of
excitations here which is a wave we have
a bunch of excitations over here which
might be a field or a wave who knows
what it is
and if they're kind of bound to each
other and tangled
action at a distance sort of this one
affects that one
who knows by how by magic then they're
going to call that a bipolar
on okay so this is how it goes and
what is a polaron do well it describes
an electron moving in a dielectric
crystal
i mean we're not talking about an
electron we're talking about the motion
of an electron now okay okay
uh let's look at another one here okay
just going down for a couple of these so
you get the hang of it that's all i'm
doing here
and they invent these strange names
let's see if i can pronounce this thing
bogo lubon vogel yubon okay
it's a quasi that occurs in
superconductors
what are we talking about we talking
about science
physics now we're talking about
technology
gadgets things inventions okay
where superconductivity is characterized
by
a condensation of cooper pairs which you
see at the bottom there
in the same ground uh quantum state
buggled you fob
because it's got both named bogel yubon
and bogel yubov
i think it was because it was a russian
who invented this stuff
quasis or crazies are elementary
excitations that's what they are
above the ground state okay like an
excited state of an atom that
you have the ground state and you have
the excited state and this is
above the ground state okay uh which are
superpositions okay
of the excitations of negatively charged
electrons
and positively charged positively
charged electron holes
not positrons these are holes which are
the
absence of electrons because they have
the
absence of electrons they're going to
call that positive
and they're going to have superpositions
of these
vibrations excitations
i mean i lost track by now you know what
they're talking about
and they're going to call these cooper
pairs and and
this is uh what they're going to use the
vocal u-bond
for they're going to say it's uh
it's a quasi-particle it's an excitation
of elementary
ex it's it's a it's an excitation of uh
elementary excitation that's what it
is pure excitation excitement all around
that's all this stuff is what's a coop
repair a pair of electrons
bound together at low temperatures so
they're going to take
these electrons are going to freeze
these things
they're going to see what kind of
vibrations they have they're going to
look at the holes that
are vibrating vibration of holes which
is the absence
of an electron which is
again you take the electron out of the
valence band and somehow
something remains vibrating in there and
it's not
localized it's just a bunch of
vibrations of nothing's
of the absence of electrons that's what
the
bugal u-bond has to do with that's what
you're paying for
uh i might need a beer after this too
just to get my sanity back okay
well if you ever wanted to ask here it
is i finally found it for you okay
here's the answer you always wanted to
know what a configurant was right
you know what a configurant was it's
elementary
elementary configurational excitation
another excitement
okay in an amorphous material
technology which involves breaking of a
chemical bond
okay so we have a breaking of a chemical
bond and creates some kind of excitation
and that elementary configurational
uh what is it excitation that's going to
be called a configuron
in terms of that whole thing turns into
a particle
now what sense can can that possibly
make in science and physics and trying
to understand how this universe works
absolutely none okay and then we have
the this line obviously
we learned this in kindergarten right
localized collective
excitation another excitation bunch of
excitation
associated with what this location in
crystalline solids
okay so you have a dislocation something
out of place and we'll call that a this
line
okay what's a fraction well that's a
sub-dimensional
particle you know you have dimensions
and it's like a quarter of a dimension
what's the dimension uh dimension is
direction and orthogonality that's what
a dimension is
okay three dimension you say uh the
table is three dimension what do you
mean it's got length within height
and these guys partition the dimension
they cut it in half they cut direction
in half
they have half a direction maybe a
quarter of direction so they call it
a fractal or a fraction of a dimension
that's what a
fraction is it's a it's uh what it's got
an emergent
topological quasi
quasi uh crazy excitation they're all
excitations
they get excited about these things a
collective quantized vibration
or excitation or movement jumping around
back
and forth okay that's where the
oscillation
which is immobile when in isolation
so the only way it can move vibrate is
when you put it with some
with its buddies when it was isolated
the fractal doesn't move it it doesn't
vibrate
there's no excitement fragment has no
excitement when it's alone
and don't forget the very important hold
on okay
also known as a charge on why because it
comes from hole in charge
right one of three quasis along with
spinons
and orbitons okay those are very
important particles okay you gotta
have them for for the test on friday
okay
that electrons and solids are able to
split into
during process of spin charge separation
they're going to take the spin away from
the charge
if that makes any sense to you here we
have two concepts
that belong for example to an electron
top
the top is spinning and we're going to
take the charge over here and the spin
over there because a part company
whatever that means in mathematics
when extremely tightly confined at
temperatures close to absolute zero
yeah they're studying a lot of this
stuff what happens to materials
um um at look very low temperatures
because they want to see if they can
develop these what super computers as
they call them
or quantum computers and what they're
going to be doing is they're going to
freeze them going to bring them down to
very low temperatures to see
what kind of effects they have they have
maybe less resistance
maybe not as much heat in the
little chip so they can make them
smaller see one of the problems you have
with semiconductors the smaller you make
them
the geometries are closer together and
so they heat up
and you can't make them any smaller
because they heat up even more and more
and more and finally they melt
but what if you were to cool them down
and freeze them
well then you can get into this quantum
computing this super cool world
okay that's what it's all about it's
about developing
uh technologies do they understand
what's happening in that invisible world
absolutely not they simulate it with
particles because that's
where they can apply their equation they
can put that number in any equation
but then they're not interested in in
the physical interpretation all they're
interested in is
what effect does it have and can i use
it for something
can i make something out of it can i
invent something can i make
money that's what it's all about that's
why there's investment in that world
that's
that's why so many of these so-called
physicists mathematical physicists
mathematicians is even a better one
because they do
all their explanations are magical and
they claim at the end of the
show that they don't understand you know
the quantum world of course not not if
you're going to simulate it with
particles you'll never understand it
because
there are no such things as discrete
particles you would not be able to
explain action at a distance
with particles much less can you explain
them with
quasis because quasi's are localized
vibrations of many particles
which they turn into a single particle
and they call that
a crazy crazy this crazy that they're
all crazy
okay um here's uh maybe one of the last
ones i'll
mention here okay this is the exciton
okay how's that for for a particle name
i mean if they're all excitations i'm
sure the exciton
has to be the number one particle you
know
what is it it's a bound state of an
electron and
an electron hole so these things are
bound
when you hear the word bound it doesn't
mean bound like
nothing in mathematical physics is what
it
what the word says spin is not spin
particle is not
particle and bound is not bound bound
does not mean that it's tied like
you know by a string or a wire or a
cable
that's not what bound means bound means
that action at a distance by magic
that's what bound mean bound means
entanglement
this particle does something this one
follows suit
and imitates it or acts
in the opposite direction or whatever in
other words it responds to this one
through magic only through magic magic
wand okay it's done
through magic it's called black magic
they don't understand it they just say
it does so we've proven it here's the
equation
and we saw it in the we observed it in
the lab
did they observe the whatever happened
in between the mechanism
absolutely not they cannot explain that
at all okay
so it's important to understand that
okay
uh says an exciting form when material
absorbs a
photon of higher energy than its band
gap and so on
well you can read that later on again
all these
quasis uh they have nothing to do with
science
because you cannot explain any phenomena
of nature any invisible phenomenon of
nature
just by saying that it's an excitation
of many
particles okay uh i do
want to mention one last one only just
to rub it in
okay here it is i think it's this one
yeah uh this called the dropleton
uh which are droplets of electrons and
holes why do i mention this one
well i mentioned it because i just want
to show that this is a
formal paper written on these uh
droppeltons
and what these people are saying as you
can read it here
is that it's got to do solely with
technology
and let me just read here what's in that
red box there building blocks for more
complicated structures
it is often it is often possible to
incorporate
interactions in theoretical treatments
of crystalline
solids by introducing suitable
quasi-particles
that have an effective mass spin or
charge
which in turn affects the materials
conductivity
that's what they're interested in
optical response or
phase transitions additional
quasi-particles particles
interactions may also create strongly
correlated configurations yielding new
macroscopic phenomena in other words
they're interested in the
in the phenomena in the behavior they're
not interested in the explanation
such as as the emergence of a mod
insulator superconductivity or the
pseudogap phase of high temperature
superconductors
in other words they're interested in in
technology but see the interesting part
is that they mentioned the exciton
the bi excitons and the poly excitons
and they talk about the existence of
these particles as if taken for granted
of course they never defined the word
exist in physics so we don't know what
they're talking about when they say
exist but look in the right hand side
there the
the box in red again said we present
experimental and theoretical what
evidence for the existence of quantum
droplets
in an electron hole plasma
so these people are claiming that
they've proven the existence and they
present
evidence which is what mathematical
physics all about about persuading your
colleagues
that you found it that you discovered it
so that you get some kind of prize of
recognition or whatever
and that's what it's all about it's like
saying we saw something in the lab
what did you see well we saw what was it
a droppelton
what do you mean you saw a propleton
what is it droppleton what's up
okay yeah i understood that and
what are they talking about they're
talking about a behavior
collective behavior and why is it
important
well it's the only relevance of it is in
terms of
physics in terms of i'm sorry of
technology
that's all they're interested in they're
interested in technology and if you can
do
about some kind of gadget with it or
make something
more efficient or you can run it maybe
at colder temperatures
uh or faster or longer life or
any of those things that you can improve
on an existing
device or gadget or whatever
then for them it's worth a lot because
that translates into money it's part of
the research and development of a lot of
companies
so there's no problem there i just want
you to understand that it's got nothing
to do with physics physics is about
explaining
about understanding what's going on in
that secret world
if you're going to dismiss the
explanation the physical interpretation
say i described it
i saw it i observed it i called it i
gave it a name
fancy name okay uh
yeah and it does this and it's gonna
save so much money or it's gonna
create a faster device that we can sell
much better than the competition
and so it's going to earn the company
money well yeah all that's got to do
with business with
you know with uh developing research and
development with
manufacturing that sort of thing it's
got nothing to do
with explaining how mother nature runs
her shop doesn't explain anything about
electricity it doesn't explain anything
whatsoever about
how magnetism works how gravity works
how light works how the atom works
that's where it fails and that's where
it's misleading because a lot of people
say
what do you mean the mathematicians
don't understand that they cannot
explain that they don't understand
quantum mechanics
we wouldn't have all this technology if
they didn't understand
well no it's because experiment and
technology have nothing to do with
science
you can do an experiment what's the
purpose of the experiment either to
reinforce your preconceived beliefs
notions or that of others it's an
experiment you use to convince people
it's used to persuade that's the only
purpose of an experiment
it's that you satisfy yourself that
whatever theory you have in your mind
you confirmed it with that experiment
and you haven't convinced everybody else
but then you go to the
court and you show it to the to the
jurors
and you say look here's an experiment
that proves my theory
proves and i prove the existence of the
plasmon or the
bion or uh any of those
particles there by polaron i proved it
existence because look
here it is and see you see that
vibration that's the polaron
that's how it works an experiment is
only used
to persuade people i mean you can run
any experiment you want at home when you
come to the conference we need for you
to explain
what you understood or how it works we
you need to explain the mechanism
if you're just going to tell me a
description say yeah a chair has four
legs
well that's not much of a science you
know and this is what these people are
doing they say we observed what did you
observe
well we observed these vibrations these
oscillations these excitations
and and we gave it a name we called it
the what
bipolar or the phonon
oh okay and what does the phone do well
it makes you a lot of money okay then i
like
that's what it's all about where's the
explanation for
for what's happening in that secret
world in that invisible world
for that you need a mechanism and for
mechanisms you need what
you need objects you need to do them
with things
for that you need to know what a thing
is okay
anyways um this is what um
what i'm proposing okay
uh i took the trouble to put them
you know like mendeleev did with the uh
with the uh standard with a model of uh
of chemical elements okay
and i did something similar with the
crazies and i put them there so that i
hope i get credit for this you know
somewhere
and while i was doing this i did my own
research
and don't laugh at me but you know it
took me a whole week i was
watching day after night i think i'm
coming back
okay i'm reconnected uh anyways i was
watching my curtain for a whole week
okay and this is what i saw
i found an excitation one day
and because of that you know i i
i call this excitation this collective
excitation
of the cloth and i called it a
phantom but you know because of the
rules the laws of quantum mechanics i
had to change the name to a phantom
because everything has to end in
the letter n okay so there you have the
phantom that's my contribution to the
quasis
okay and all the others are there in uh
nice neat fashion so that you can locate
them
they don't belong to the standard model
of elementary particles they belong to
the standard model of quasis
okay so i hope i get credit for that
okay anyways
here's my conclusions on the equations
okay you can take this to the bank okay
quasis are not particles
they're not corpuscles in any sense of
the word
at all why they use the word particle to
mislead you i have no idea
maybe it's just for that just to mislead
you to think that they're doing physics
when they're not
okay uh they were invented for what for
inventions
so they have an invention for an
invention what's the tech
that's what's the point of it technology
making money
that's all it is um its interest is
only in the application for gadgets for
devices you know making something faster
uh running at colder temperatures
uh maybe longer lasting a lot of reasons
for these things
but it has to do with looking or
or discovering behaviors that were not
seen before and usually they do those at
very low temperatures
okay so they run something they can't
see in there they don't know what's
going on
they simulate it with particles and they
say well we'll call this
particle a noun particle b sorry
i meant quasi quasi particle a crazy
particle b
physical interpretations uh made with
quasis
they're all crazy they're all irrational
not one of them
is rational um
you can't simulate any invisible
intangible phenomena of nature
with any kind of particle let alone with
crazies okay
and you can't even do it with classical
particles
you know the people who use the ether
which is a bunch of particles out there
they
simulate everything with vibrations of
lots of particles
they call those waves transverse waves
uh
or what is it the
longitudinal waves and so on uh it's all
done with particles
discrete particles and you cannot
explain anything with discrete particles
because the big problem that
particles and waves which are made of
particles
will never be able to explain is action
at a distance you cannot explain gravity
you're going to explain how this
particle over there pulls don't for
pull you cannot explain how particle
pulls on
another and so you'll never find the
word pull
in any uh simulation with particles
ether direct see whatever you want to
call it
space time made of points events all
those
uh discrete particles you'll never
explain a single
invisible phenom intangible phenomena of
mother nature
with so that's the story of quasis
okay let me get uh let me get on with uh
these uh questions and
uh comments that people made during the
week here's the first one
a person says if there is light there is
quantum jump
and it causes rotation of rope his
english was not so good but
we'll manage here also so there is
always
electricity because electricity is
rotation of rope
am i correct uh no
you're not correct okay so let's uh
clarify that for this gentleman
okay let's find out what it is here it
is under the rope model
this is the difference between light and
electricity and electricity is not light
okay here you have two models light
is the quantum jump of an atom in other
words it pumps back and forth there is
no particle that goes from
energy level to energy level higher
energy level to lower energy level and
back
none of that what you have is a membrane
which is in the case of the s orbitals
they are spherical
okay all the s orbitals are spherical
and we're just going to treat with those
because they're simpler and it jumps
back and forth
by doing so it torques the rope and it
is that
torsion which we call light okay
is that what electricity is no that's
what light is what is electricity
electricity is a row
of merged atom shells in other words
those balls that you see there those are
membranes
and in this case we simulated them again
with s
orbitals only and so we bound them
together they're merged
and the whole row of atoms okay
atoms could be molecules also and
they spin in place and it is that
spinning in place
which we call electricity
so no uh the torquing of the rope is not
electricity it's the torquing
of a row of merged atom shells
which we call a serpentine serpentine
spins in situ in place okay another
common
question here it is fellow says
how do you find out if a single
homogeneous
uh sphere is spinning because i talked
about a top spinning the other day
we talked about it with my son the fact
that spinning means that
you know uh an atom or a component
or a side or whatever region
assuming it's made of a single piece
right uh
goes in the other it goes to the other
side we call that a spin
okay so it involves two two locations of
at least
one region object atom whatever you want
to put in there okay
you have to monitor a single point on
its surface on its equator
if the point moves about an axis of the
sphere then it is spinning
there exists two points where the sphere
will be spinning and this test will fail
just make two tests with a single points
90 degrees apart if you touch a spinning
gyroscope your contact point is a single
point and if your finger moves the
gyroscope is spinning
people have been brainwashed to
exhaustion
that experiments have something to do
with science
and they so they they want to prove the
word spin
by running an experiment that's not how
we do it in science
how do we do it in science well this is
the way we do it in science we don't do
experiments in science never
do an experiment in science it's only
irrational people who do
who don't understand science who do
experiments in science
science we don't do experiments in
science we explain them
and we do not observe we do not god
okay which is what mathematical physics
does no we do not gog we do not observe
or do experiments what we do
is explain them science is about
explaining not about observing or
doing experiments okay so here's the
answer to that here you have your top
okay it's do we know if that top is
spinning
well the only way we're gonna know is by
defining
the words we have to know what the word
spin means
okay we have to have a definition for
the word spin
what is it to cause or turn around
rapidly as on an
axis turtle world that's on
dictionary.com
uh maybe there's better definitions out
there but uh
here rotate this gives us the idea to
cause to turn around
and access our center point to revolve
and according to the wikipedia a
circular movement of an
object around the center or point of
rotation
the point here is that if you want to
define spin
you need at least two objects two points
or one object at two locations you need
two
okay and we don't run an experiment what
we do is define the word spin and then
we'll know if a top spins or not
if it meets the definition of spin
and again here you have uh spinning of a
sphere
and by doing so you can see that any
point that you look in there it's going
to be at two locations
or it's going to move with respect to
another point
so that's what we call spin okay
you gotta define spin not do an
experiment to prove
spin and which is what this file did
okay here's another question
comment there it is says a field is not
a bunch of numbers
which i said it is okay the other day
it's a collection of lines
what is a line
is there such a thing as a line i mean
it'd be nice if you drew a line if it's
a physical object
okay there is no such thing as a line in
uh
mathematical physics geometry uh
they have a 1d line in other words it's
made out of a single
dimension uh coordinate vector or
whatever you want to call that it's a
number line
that's what a line is a number line and
uh
so a collection of lines doesn't tell us
anything you have to tell us what a line
is
and a line is a
got an example there somewhere maybe i
should have put one up there but anyway
line is two-dimensional
rectangle elegated random rectangle
line is a two dimensional thing if
you're gonna i mean just
look at any line that you can see it's
two dimensional guarantee
at least okay it could be three
dimensional but for sure it's two
dimensional it's got two dimensions
width and height no line that
there's no object in the entire universe
that doesn't have at least two
dimensions
okay all objects are two and three
dimensions
no objects that are zero or one
dimensional no objects beyond
four or beyond okay so there is no such
thing as a line
that's the first problem okay and so
he uh lines cannot exert a force and
line of force cannot tell us anything
because
there is no such monster as line of
force you got to tell us what a line is
that's the issue that's where that's
where it would be nice
if uh if you were to put that in there
what a line is
okay so what is a field well we look it
up we look at the definition there you
have it
physical quantity what is a quantity a
number what is it a quantity an amount
it's a
value that's what a quantity is
field is a quantity okay represented by
a number
or another tensor okay so what is a
field it's a quantity represented by a
number or tensor which is a number
that has a value value what is a value
it's a number
for each point in space and time so what
is a field
number that's what it is and there you
see it on the right bunch of vectors
that's what they are
field is a bunch of vectors what is a
vector
vector has according to math uh
it says magnitude and direction we don't
know about direction but for sure it's
got
magnitude okay direction only physical
objects can have direction numbers don't
have
direction number lines don't have
directions
uh and then here you have it in the
dictionary.com
field the influence that's what a field
is it's the influence
whatever influence is and i have to
separate this in pieces because people
don't know how to read
they read and they don't understand what
they read so i have to kind of chop it
off so they can see what what the
problem is
field is not an influence and field is
uh
well you could say it's an influence but
if it's an influence obviously it's a
concept it's not a thing
and if it's a quantity it's not a thing
and so it's some agent
that means we're not talking about the
agent we're talking about the
influence of the agent okay so that's
the problem
okay and it says considered as existing
now it doesn't exist because you have to
define the word exist in order to know
what existing means
okay you can't say it exists that a
number exists not in physics
maybe an ordinary speech a number can
exist okay so
uh yeah field is a number and you might
say well you know
um there's something physical there uh
field
it's got to be something physical my two
magnets the little
black round circles there okay and there
you have it
and you say well what's in between here
well you say it's a magnetic field
yeah what is a field can we have a field
without a magnet
and so you have to identify what a field
is
what is in between these two what
physical object
is there and you say well i can't touch
or see anything between these two
magnets so
a field is not mediated by objects
well then you're doing physics with
spirits
you're filling in that same space that
blank
you're filling it with ghosts with black
magic
that's what you're doing you're saying
that this is physical
this is physical right we have two
physical entities
and they're pulled together by nothing
by
nothing that is between them and you say
well there's a field between them
okay what is a field do we have a field
out here that we can
take and move it around can you bring a
field
to uh the conference can you make it
visible
and you say well i sprinkle iron filings
over and i see these lines
so what are those lines i mean if if
it's a line obviously those are discrete
lines
now there's one line is separated from
another line what are those lines
are they physical entities are they just
abstract concepts that are bringing
these two things together
and that's why for the for the purposes
of physics we have to define
what an object is and what a concept is
separate those two
we can't do physics with concepts
because otherwise you're doing
irrational so-called physics you're not
doing physics at all
you're doing black magic you can't move
concepts you can't say that a magnetic
field is mediated or whatever's in there
those lines
are just abstractions you can't say
there's no physical object there no
there
there had better be a physical object
there otherwise
we're all crazy okay otherwise you're
doing black magic
so yeah a field is mediated into a rope
model very simple it's mediated by
threads
okay real threads you know i mean you
know uh
like the thread you sew but obviously at
a much
uh thinner level way beyond plank level
uh you know plank length uh level
okay okay another uh
question common here here it is
well says so the thread is not a
standalone object
is it a concept or dependent object
my god uh here's a thread okay
let me show you a thread i think this is
it
there's a thread now is there any other
object
together with that thread i show you
that
i can put a thread all by itself without
any other object in its vicinity
so that's not a dependent object in the
sense that it doesn't depend on another
object
for me to call it thread i can point to
a thread without any other
object in the field of view in the frame
of reference in whatever you want to
call it
okay i don't need any other there could
be a single thread only in the universe
that's all there is
and we don't need to see any other
object next to it to understand what a
thread is
okay that's not the case with a field
for example field you need the
magnet because without the magnet you
don't have a field
that's the problem there you don't have
a standalone field
okay and what is an object what is that
which has shape and i hopefully
that thread has shaped there you see
something there
i can point to it so clearly that has
shape
okay okay here's another comment
question paul says what
says uh show us a square without
a drawing of it
[Laughter]
well first of all it doesn't matter if i
draw it or not i mean what's the point
of
saying that you you know i can't draw it
drawing is not the the object the object
what you see there has shape on its own
it's the finished product not drawing it
or
weighing it or moving it or doing
anything with it i don't have to draw it
okay but there i drew a or took a
picture of a tree
is that not an object well it has shape
and that's the definition of the word
object
and all you have to do you know you say
how do you call it an object well i call
it an object because
both of those objects have shape okay
both of them have shape uh is
does any of those two not have shape
okay so that's the answer you have to
the question you have to answer
and then the other issue if you don't
like that definition you don't
think that it's the valid definition all
you have to do is define the word object
uh very rigorously
and be able to defend it defend your
definition
get in the ring and fight for your
definition let's see if you can
you know i fight for my definitions
hopefully you can do the same you cannot
define the word object don't even try
don't even
don't even put a question because until
you answer what is an object you gotta
define the word object
then we can have a discussion otherwise
there is no discussion what discussion
can there be if you you
if you can't tell the world what you
mean by the word object what you think
an object is
i'm telling you what an object is it's
that which has shape uh
if you have a different definition very
simple put the definition on then we'll
know what it is
but defend it be able to defend your
definition of the word object and i've
you know done a lot of anal
analysis of the word
object so you know uh all you have to do
is look at some of the previous
videos and you'll know what the
arguments are okay
so be careful when you want to define
the word object it's my greatest
contribution to science the definition
of the word object
okay i'm an expert on the word by the
way i claim to be an expert
i have a definition for nothing now
oh good good we have a definition for
the word nothing nothing
object that doesn't exist that you
present physics on
okay now all you have to do is define
the word exist we have no idea what you
mean by the word exist
and it turns out that you have to define
the word nothing
and the word uh object or something
before you define the word exist
okay so we need to know what the word
exist is because otherwise you know you
can't even start
uh and before you can define exist you
have to define what an object is and the
antonym of object is nothing so those
two words always precede really
the word exist so you can't say you're
gonna use the word exist to define a
word nothing
you have to define object and nothing
before you define the word exist
in physics okay that's
that's the the sequence it's an
unavoidable
sequence otherwise tell us what you mean
by exist and we'll have an idea
hopefully you don't use the antonym of
nothing for
to define the word exist then okay uh
file says the thread is a concept
in the context of one universe uh
yeah uh one guy answered the universe in
itself is a concept
though and he took the word dried out of
my mouth so let's clarify that to make
sure we
understand why that's the case okay
and so what we have to do first is
define the word concept we have to know
what a concept is
an object is that which has shape what
is a concept a word that
embodies or invokes two objects
in other words it's a relation or two
words treated as objects for example the
word universe
universe is comprised of two words
space and matter or
objects okay so we have objects and we
have space we call that
the whole thing which is not a thing
it's a concept we call that
universe so universe is a concept
because we're treating space
as a physical object we're assuming for
the
momentarily that we have two things
there we have the object
or the objects plural and we have space
we have two objects we have a concept
okay
so that's why the word universe is a
concept yeah it is so
the single thread remember what the
single thread
is and what it represents first of all
here we have the single thread
and i put two of them there because
people are going to say well does the
thread exist does it have location
i showed that the other day yeah here
you have the thread you have two threads
so they have location because one has
distance with respect to the other
no problem there okay the thread exists
if you're going to talk about thread the
only context where the
global thread the universal thread is
with respect to another thread otherwise
we have no use for the thread
itself locally we use the thread only
for
constructing atoms the membranes the
electron shells
and for magnetism other than that we
have no use at all
for the thread okay and uh what do
those reds represent again they
represent two universes
that's what the thread represents in
other words all the matter in the
universe
is represented by those threads the
thread underlies
all the matter in the universe
okay so that's the foundation of the
rope model
okay we don't call it the thread
hypothesis we call it the
rope hypothesis because we're interested
in the
local uh functioning or behavior
of what light gravity you know all those
things are mediated
by a rope and only in the case of
magnetism isn't mediated by the thread
but not by the global threats mediated
by many threads
locally okay many portions of that
global threat of that universal threat
so we have no use for the universal
thread people who harp about on the
existence of the thread
all they're talking about is the
existence of a second thread
that's the only context of the existence
of the threat
otherwise it just underlies all matter
in the universe
okay and here's another question another
comment
fellow says he says
if there is nothing between two objects
they are one object
right yeah essentially there you have
two
uh cubes two elongated uh boxes whatever
cubes and on the bottom you have a
more elongated box okay so again what
you're what you're talking about there
is
is uh made it something made of a single
piece
and again it's an idealized situation
okay and all we're saying here is that
in the case of the one on the top you
have two boxes
and hopefully if you're talking about
two they're separated by something
which is nothing which is what
ultimately
space okay and in the bottom case it's
not separated
yeah so we're assuming that we have the
same volume but
it's a single piece again so there is no
space
in the middle of that piece it's made
out of a single piece and
yeah it's just a different object okay
and again these are idealized objects we
treat them as if they were made of a
single piece
like if god made them you know just of a
single piece
so again these are idealized situations
yeah you have to have space between any
two objects and remember like i said the
other day if you have a chair and a
table
we see them in our everyday world as two
distinct objects
but keep in mind all the atoms from the
chair
are connected to all the atoms of the
table
that's going to be the light that goes
from one object to the other is going to
be the cause
that underlies gravity between these two
objects
you have to have a physical mechanism to
explain gravity
you can't do that with abstract concepts
you can't do it with
magic you got to have a physical object
what is a physical object
that which has shape okay another common
question
file says is the black in between
a vacuum uh another fellow answered
vacuum is nothing so
essentially he answered the question for
me
saved me some work uh vacuum is the
black stuff
so you can't have black stuff between
two vacuums or vacuum between two black
stuffs
because it's all black stuff it's all
vacuum it's all space it's all nothing
nothing what is nothing that which
doesn't have shape
nothing is the opposite of something but
it's something that which
has shaved we're done now we can use
those words consistently
rationally in a scientific dissertation
this or one of physics okay
another common question here goes
paula says says is space nothing
without shape
[Laughter]
that could be interpreted in two ways
the question is whether
space has shape itself and if you
is almost like a word wizard are you
there you're saying
uh here we have space which is that
which doesn't have
shape and you're saying that nothing
without shape well yeah that's the
definition
and the other one uh interpretation
could be if there's nothing within space
to use that term in other words assuming
space
forms the backdrop to every something
out there
uh that which has shape uh
if you remove that if you remove all the
objects from the universe uh is space
still
nothing is the space not have shape
for that we go to the definitions period
just follow the definitions you won't
get hurt
space equals nothing they're synonyms
okay space that which doesn't have shape
okay very straightforward so just follow
the definition nobody gets hurt
okay promise i won't send a tony in
there and collect
on on these definitions uh in other
words space doesn't have shape with or
without something
being it it doesn't matter
okay just follow the definitions and we
promise we won't hurt anyone
okay here's a couple more questions
first one foul says what
says quantum particle is indeed wave
particle
duality and it's about way in its
and if it's about waves the equation of
waves can always be represented using
complex numbers
yeah we can represent the wave particle
particle wave as they do in mathematical
physics
with an equation okay with a function or
whatever
but what you're looking at when you're
talking about wave you're talking about
vectors wave is
is is a misleading term
because people think it's a noun
it's not a noun for the purposes of
physics
in ordinary speech it's a noun you can
talk about the wave
not in physics in physics there is no
such object called
the wave okay wave
is a verb wave is action
pure action what is waving they never
figured that out
the they say it's the ether a bunch of
particles that's
what's always been assumed for the last
400 years at least
the ether has been a bunch of particles
that are waving up and down why they
wave up and down why one
particle follows the other we have no
idea they never explained that
they cannot explain how one particle
pulls
or compels another one to do anything
from a distance
so they cannot explain it with particles
again the particle hypothesis cannot
explain any phenomenon
invisible intangible phenomenal mother
nature
so what is a wave wave is just a bunch
of vectors that are
that they've set in motion what is a
vector
magnitude essentially they say it's
direction but it's just magnitude
just a number what they're moving is
numbers what you're staring at
is an arrow that they put in new of
a number they put an arrow there and you
say okay now i understand because i can
see something moving on the screen
no you're staring at numbers that's what
the those arrows are those arrows are
just
numbers that are moving so it's a mirage
that you're staring
at you're not staring at anything that
is real what they've done is they
replaced the numbers with arrows they
call them vectors they put them in
motion
they put a as collective motion what a
quasi another crazy
is that what a wave is and and they have
these
vectors and they're oscillating you say
okay now i understand because i see
something moving on the screen
now you're staring at a bunch of numbers
a bunch of vectors keep that in mind
whenever you look at that
sine wave that they show they're moving
it's ridiculous
it's because they have no idea what's
out there in the invisible world of
mother nature that's why they have to do
this
okay okay i think i have a final
question here
or issue file says
survey says there goes
says i asked about invisible intangible
physical object double rope single
thread passing through each other
invisible intangible physical objects
what yeah because
an object is not that which you can see
or touch so
so visibility and tangibility have
nothing to do
with the definition of the word object
the word object that which has shape
again he who has a better definition
better mousetrap
hey just put it on there and be able to
defend it i mean it's not an issue of
copying and saying well i found this in
the dictionary and i'm going to follow
that because
everybody in the universe follows that
yeah i don't care if you can't defend it
it's worthless yeah so it doesn't matter
how many people stand behind you it's
just you and me buddy on this island
okay so you gotta defend it if i knock
your definition out you can't use
authority and say well this is what
everybody else believes
that's that's worth zip okay
and the question is can you see or touch
the mediator of gravity you know i let
go
the pencil the pen okay
i can't see or touch anything here other
than the air but we could do this in
on the moon you know as it's done by
neil armstrong no not neil armstrong one
of these other guys
and they let go and it falls always to
the ground
but we can't see or touch anything here
other than the air and here on earth
and so uh what do you propose you
propose that
it's done by spirits black magic is that
how gravity is done
what pulls the pencil to the floor why
does it pull it to the sky
what are you going to use a concept such
as mass a concept such as gravity and
say gravity pulls it down
so far you haven't explained anything
all you did is give a name to a
description
you say this description that things
fall down we call it gravity
great and what pulls it down
like you know i want to pull on a horse
and i can explain that to you i said
well i tied a
rope around the horse's neck and i'm
pulling
on it and now you understand the
mechanism
the way i pulled on the horses with the
rope
but imagine i had no rope and i go like
this and i'm pulling on the horse
and of course you know responds to my
hands moving
back and forth now you ask well how did
you do that bill
what invisible intangible object that
you use to pull on the horse's neck
what am i going to say i pulled it with
gravity i pulled it with
mass i pulled it with force with field
now i got to put a physical object there
i got to put a rope i got to put a a
wire a
cable a string thread some elongated
object maybe a coaxial
i got to put a physical object between
my hands
and the horse i can't say i pulled it by
magic like quantum does so yeah
it better be a physical object and you
say well but i can touch
the mediator between your hands and
the um and the horse yeah
you can but mother nature does it with
invisible intent does the same thing
with invisible intangible objects that's
where the trick comes in
so whatever you use it better be
invisible and intangible
and does that doesn't out um outlaw the
word
object because the word object has
nothing to do with see or touch with
tangibility or visibility
object is that which has shape not that
which you can see or touch
so c and touch have nothing to do with
it and can you touch her
the mediator of magnetism is the agent
that does magnetism
a ghost is that what you propose we're
going to do this with what
with ether we're going to do it with um
i don't know plasma uh what other
waves what what invisible
uh entity do you propose and it better
be a
physical entity otherwise you know
you're going to use a concept
all you're doing is giving a description
so you can't use the word force you
can't use the word
energy you can't use the word um
what is it mass charge any of those
words those are all concepts
mathematical concepts you can't say
you're going to pull on something with
charge or with electricity or with
plasma
all those are concepts not one of those
is a physical
standalone object okay those in fact
they're all
concepts in motion
i mean objects in motion okay uh
what is plasma plasma is ionized ionized
ed
right gas that's what plasma is it's
something in motion
what is a field it's vibrating something
whatever's vibrating in there we don't
know
right but field is the vibration of that
something
again another crazy all these crazies
okay so what do we
respond to this gentleman here it is
uh we have the single piece and the
segmented piece okay
and some people who even like the rope
model
uh they say well how does a thread go
through another thread how does a rope
go through another rope
and what they propose is that the thread
is segmented
okay and so we have a problem with that
because see uh
yeah you explained you can explain this
with uh you can explain this how
maybe a thread goes through another let
me show you this
okay you can see how thread goes through
another if they're segmented
but you created a monster because now
you cannot explain
the integrity of the thread how does one
particle
segment or whatever you want to call
those individual discrete things
okay pull on another one how does it one
of those red balls pull on another red
ball
why does the second red ball follow the
first red ball
and that's only the first of your
problems you got a lot more problems
than that by
creating segmented things okay
now you cannot use a segmented
thread if you're going to follow the
thread model
you have to assume that the thread goes
through another thread it has that
property you can think of it maybe as
crossing two light beams i mean here it
is i
i showed it the other day here you have
a light let me just point it
okay laser pointer i just
put the light on and you know you have
two
lights essentially and they cross each
other
they don't bounce the the light whatever
light is
those things are not interfering with
each other they go right through each
other
and so the question is is light mediated
by a physical
object so what is a physical object that
which i shake not that which you can
touch or see
so it has shape whatever is in there but
it doesn't have the ability to touch
the other one now we can make sense of
what mother nature has out there
we have a physical object that underlies
light
in this case the rope but these ropes
have the ability to go through each
other
and that's what people say what do you
mean yeah we don't see that in our macro
world
but but again light goes through light
let me show you one more time here in
light okay one
let me show you this one it's a little
bigger okay
okay okay here it goes
we have these two lights let me put this
one on
okay and light goes through light
there are no photons you know bouncing
off of that
okay light goes through light
and so
you gotta explain how light goes through
light
and what mediates light does
is does light is light mediated by a
physical object by an object
something that has shape and if not then
what is it mediated by by
ghosts by phantoms by spirits
hopefully there is a physical entity
mediating light physical
that which has shape what what are we
proposing it's a rope
what are we saying a rope interconnects
any two atoms
and a rope has the ability to go through
another rope just like light has the
ability to go through light
at mother nature's microscopic level
uh the ropes do not have the ability to
touch
uh at least at that level okay
touching as i said invisibility
require um accumulation
many yeah you can't see one atom but you
can see the table and the table's made
out of atoms
each one of which you cannot see so the
only way to see a table is having a
bunch of them
and the same thing happens with the rope
and the same thing with threads
at least for for touching visibility is
a different issue again when you're
talking about something so
microscopically thin
that there is no way you can ever see a
thread or a rope
yes beyond human ability anyways with
that